hello my beautiful witches and warlocks
it's time for a new episode of American
Horror Story apocalypse so fill up your
tank and prepare for biology class
because this one's a doozy
Cordelia wakes up among the burned ashes
of row B shows Academy for exceptional
young ladies it seems everything around
her has fallen to a nuclear blast but
miraculously she's still alive but
things get worse for Cordelia she's
surrounded by ravenous mutated cannibals
she tries to use her powers but they
don't seem to work eventually being
overcome by the horde and ripped apart
as Michael Langdon wearing his sexy
demonic old man face laughs maniacally
but then we realized it was all a dream
she wakes up and we're in the past
timeline the one where she fainted at
the end remember there are currently two
timelines present-day where Michael has
taken over the outpost and past where
Michael has returned with Madison and
Queenie in her dream Cordelia called out
all her witchy sisters except for
Madison and of course she had to say
something about it she is a brief moment
to hug her friends and then says she
wants to see the boy referring to
Michael but as we'll find out Cordelia
doesn't think this was a dream it's an
omen of the future of the impending rise
of Michael and the apocalypse to come
and if this is indeed a vision what of
Cordelia's inability to use her power we
do learn later in this episode her
powers are fading will this come true
later on and is her death in the vision
an omen of things to come the witches
and warlocks meet and Cordelia admits
she's impressed with Michael's skills
Cordelia tells them her dream was a
vision of the future it's filled with
cataclysm fire death she saw a man but
not a man a demonic entity another hint
that Michael is not a warlock but
possessed with the powers of Satan John
Henry thinks it might be a warning and
something in Cordelia's blood tells her
the only hope of surviving depends on
what they do next the reference to
something in her blood reminds me of
episode one where Tim Lee that's Timmy
and Emily were chosen for the outpost
due to their exceptional genetics
something tells me they'll be back in
two weeks time at the rise of the Blood
Moon Michael will be given the test of
the seven wonders the same test Zoey
Madison Queenie and misty were given at
the end of season three the Blood Moon
is also interesting the phenomenon
whereby the moon in total eclipse
appears reddish in color across the
globe there have been reports of satanic
or witchcraft rituals which take place
on this rare occasion myrtle de Christ
Cordelia's decision to let Michael
perform the test reminding him that no
male has ever succeeded and if he passes
he will become the next supreme but let
us remember there have been several
clues to suggest he may not be male
myrtle gives it to Cordelia explaining
that the Alpha is merely a child's tale
alpha being the legend told by Ariel of
a male supreme she spurts how men have
caused pain throughout history referring
to Attila the Hun Herod the Great and of
course Mark Zuckerburg just sick mom
could you get me my Frodo ray Cordelia
questions her own leadership she's
scared what if it's her own hubris
preventing her from relinquishing her
title to Michael
Myrtle makes a good point passing the
seven wonders doesn't mean one is fit to
lead the coven she references Cordelia's
mother Fiona who put her own vanity
before that of the coven she goes on to
explain that magic can be found anywhere
take for example their star pupil
Mallory Mallory heals a doe in the
forest notice the gemstones in which
symbology you like the moon on her rings
she also wears a crown the crown another
subtle clue that she's not a witch but
something more well Michael possesses
destructive power gained by what is
likely a demonic source could Mallory be
the opposite the foil to Michael
Satanism remember when he was
communicating with his father during the
satanic ritual in Episode three that he
said he thought he killed them all was
he referring to something more than
witches perhaps angels Myrtle even
explains that Mallory's powers are
unlike any magic she's ever seen she
asked Cordelia to delay the test but
Cordelia tells her time is of the
essence her powers are fading we see a
gruesome wound on her stomach and she
tells Myrtle she's dying her fainting at
the end of episode 4 is beginning to
make more sense
Mallory interrupts this moment again
wearing flowery gold trinkets and a
crown of leaves similar to what rulers
in ancient Rome like Caesar would wear a
subtle hint that at the end of this
season she will take over Michael as
supreme she informs Cordelia that an
appointment is waiting for her
it's mr. vanderhill
saint-pierre Coco's father who we saw
get blown up in episode 1 he's thanking
Cordelia for accepting coco who is
simply not having it she feels she
doesn't deserve to be there because she
has a [ __ ] power gluten detector women
from all over Beverly Hills sought out
Coco for her gluten detecting power and
let me just say I thought it was
absolutely hilarious that princess Coco
randomly has a pony in her backyard
Cordelia tries to quell Coco's fear
saying that sensing danger in something
is a good place to start but Coco
brushes her off saying the only reason
you're accepting me is that my dad
donated as iliyan dollars
Cordelia Tasha Mallory was showing her
around the school and we get a better
sense of how these two came together in
episode 1 clearly Cordelia predicted the
bomb going off and in order to protect
the girls likely from Langdon placed a
spell on them and hid them around the
country remember in episode 1 when the
plane had no pilot and magically
adjusted after the bomb blast to avoid a
crash who was controlling that plane
likely Cordelia in the witches they've
been watching over them the warlocks
perform a blessing on Michael to prepare
him for the test you'll notice Ariel's
adorned with three ornaments around his
neck not like the others who only have
one this is to denote his higher rank of
Grand Chancellor they put water salt and
blood into a bowl and surround Michael
with it igniting it in blue flame before
performing their blessing referring to
him as their champion as Michaels
congratulated a mysterious wind blows in
just like a wind blew away the candles
from Emily's room in episode 2 which we
know was also Michaels doing John Henry
catches a glimpse of Michaels demonic
form and decides to get the hell out of
there to inform Cordelia the hold tries
to convince him to stay but John tells
him he saw the white faced man and
Michael they have a brief warlock battle
John clearly the stronger magic user and
we get this great line stand down
[ __ ] on his way to visit Cordelia John
stops for gas and meets Mead my first
instinct this probably won't go over
well but since this is the past timeline
it's likely not robot Mead just Michaels
satanic mother again likely not his
biological mother since we may get more
into that with murder house around the
corner John makes the mistake of helping
her and she rewards him by slitting his
Achilles tendons and pouring gasoline on
him what a mother won't do for her son
Michael meets with mother in the creepy
forest and his plans are revealed his
goal is to destroy the coven from within
so that he may walk the path to what he
was born to do Mead reveals that Ariel
was also in on the plan he wouldn't want
John Henry blowing their chances of
having the first male supreme but
interesting that Mead says don't tell
him about your father
Ariel has a huge ax to grind with the
witches he's tired of being beholden to
them a second fiddle he wants to make
them squirm six of the seven wonders are
then presented in an old-fashioned
black-and-white montage telekinesis
Concilium transmutation divination
pyrokinesis and vital umber Tallis
before the final and most arduous task
dissension Cordelia tasks Michael with
retrieving misty who failed the test
back in season three no other supreme
has ever been made to do this baldwin
even states that it's suicide ariel is
pissed at Cordelia michael should be
tasked with doing exactly as she did but
if Michael is to lead them in the times
ahead their leader needs to be able to
withstand anything ariel calls her out
she's fading but afraid to let go of her
role as supreme she's just like her
mother Fiona the former supreme a weak
frightened woman clinging to power
Cordelia going full nuclear on Ariel
tells him she can rip up his larynx with
a flick of her finger she's still
supreme and he better fall in line
Michael interrupts and agrees to get
misty the witches and warlocks surround
Michael as he begins the final test
dissension he chants in Latin now my
Latin is not that good but it roughly
translates to lead me in the dark at the
end of life to greet hell Michael walks
down a black hallway which I get a big
hotel Cortez vibe from as we witness
misty bringing back to life a frog and
biology class likely having to relive
over and over a traumatic experience
from her past
her own personal hell kind of like what
Madison was doing in Episode four at the
department store the teacher makes her
kill the live frog and Michael saves her
by stabbing the teacher with a scalpel
man school has changed since I was a kid
Michael awakens the witches and warlocks
thinking misty was not saved that is
until she reappears
Cordelia and mysteri unite myrtles
saying she's back from a state of
perdition often referred to as the final
state of damnation
after a brief moment of happiness
Michael seems to use his powers to make
Cordelia bleed misty being the only one
to notice this apparently after a new
supreme has reached the old one fades
away whether Ariel is being literal here
or simply her powers fade is uncertain
the witches and warlocks argue before
Cordelia raises her voice exclaiming
there can be no doubt Michael is the
next supreme before she faints again
Cordelia recovers and misty brings her
soup she says she should have left her
where she was Michael gives her the
heebie-jeebies we flash back to when
misty was in Hell and learned that after
Michael killed the teacher he somehow
communicated to the kids who were
speaking in gibberish misty says evil
was speaking to him was he talking to
Satan himself
Cordelia doesn't believe it perhaps he
was negotiating her release from hell
misty could always sense evil as a child
smell rotting souls but she's never
smelled anything like Michael describing
it as the perfume of death Myrtle
demands that he not become supreme and
Cordelia surprisingly agrees this was
all a plan by Cordelia to gauge his
powers as the old saying goes keep your
friends close and your enemies closer a
lesson from Nicolo Machiavelli who in
his book the prince provides a primer
for how to become an effective dictator
Cordelia once again reminds them that
something is coming but this time
Michael has given them an advantage he's
brought all her girls back for the fight
ahead but she says something really
interesting here that misty brought back
the first proof what is she referring to
the proof that he's demonic and if there
are more proofs who will they have to
present it to the witches celebrate when
Stevie Nicks the White Witch joins her
being a member of Fleetwood Mac sings
their song gypsy a song which she wrote
to remind her of her life before she was
famous a song to humble her the term
gypsy
also mean two things a member of a
traveling people traditionally living by
trade and fortune-telling and also a
nomadic or free spirited person
Madison is test by Cordelia to travel
and find everything she can about
Michael because of the danger he poses
could she be tasked to finding more
proof but there eavesdropped by behold
he says if they're going to dig up dirt
he should come along or he'll tell
Michael he won't go to Michael directly
because he has a bad gut feeling about
him but this is quite a change of
character from what we saw earlier when
he tried to stop John Henry from leaving
this leads me to believe that behold
will be a spy working for Michael
keeping tabs on Madison and the witches
after all we did just see him eavesdrop
Cordelia agrees to the arrangement and
gives them their destination season
One's Murder House now this is huge we
knew Murder House was going to be
featured but how it would be integrated
into the story was unknown but for now
it looks like it's going to play a role
in learning more about how Michael came
to be we know he was the child of Olivia
and Tate from season one and taken in by
Jessica Lange's character what mysteries
will this house hold and what new
information will give the witches that
may lead to finding out Michael's
weakness could it be his real mother not
to mention how this all ties in to the
eventual apocalypse remember this
episode didn't touch on any of the
present timeline where Michael confronts
Cordelia and the newly arisen witches in
the outpost my guess is the next episode
or even next couple will focus solely on
the past timeline and eventually lead to
where we left off in Episode four that's
it for this episode make sure to LIKE
and subscribe I have a new Twitter
account where you can find out when I
release my videos or if you just want to
cast a witch spell on me until next time